hey guys dude it's Monday my name is
Justin I'm here I learn again today and
you hear Dan Zach oh not only in my back
with a sweet new haircut but I'm also
back with some good news if you've been
putting off buying a PlayStation VR now
might be the time to do it yes certainly
have announced a sweet new bundle that
includes everything you'll need to
ignore reality and a pretty good game
yeah for 450 of your hard-earned dollars
you can get a full PlayStation VR
starter kit that includes the headset
PlayStation camera and to move
controllers as well as a copy of Skyrim
VR there's also a disc with 13 demos
included for you to try out feel like we
should add that that probably translates
to like $1,900 Joey yeah it's it's like
15 months rent sorry friends the bundle
launches alongside Skyrim via next week
on November 17th
Skyrim VI includes the full game and all
its expansions Dawnguard ha fire and
Dragonborn so you can now flail around
your lounge room dragon shouting and not
feel weird about it I mean I never felt
weird we at least have an excuse now
pretty boy Adventure Club 2016 aka Final
Fantasy 15 is finally getting
multiplayer the comrades expansion which
allows you and up to three friends to
team up and slash it will release next
week on November 15th
comrades casts you as a member of the
Kings glaive as you and your buds
attempt to bring the light back to the
kingdom of Lucius Lucius or Lukas what
am i oh you'll be able to create your
own avatar and other members of noctis's
inner circle will become playable in
later updates comrades boost you to
release on Halloween but was pushed back
so Square Enix could make final
adjustments to the content a pair of
beta tests for the expansion debuted in
August the first of which was plagued by
server issues while the second was
designed to fix the matchmaking issues
of the first test
hopefully that's all ironed out now you
can pick up the expansion as part of the
$25 season pass or as a standalone
download furn as yet undisclosed price
don't fret if you're more of a
single-player kind of person episode
Ignace is set to release this December
and the psvr spin-off a monster of the
deep will release November 21st
Microsoft has revealed plans to increase
in-house development by starting or
acquiring new Studios yep this story has
nothing to do the Xbox 1x but I dan one
of the problems isn't nice looking
Microsoft has earned something of an
ugly reputation of late bike shutting
studios including Lionhead and press
play and cancelling games but it sounds
like they came to turn that around xbox
bus Phil Spencer told Bloomberg our
ability to go create content has to be
one of our strengths we haven't always
invested at the same level we've gone
through ups and downs in the investment
what Microsoft has been playing catch-up
to Sony in the console sales department
hardware sales are set to rise this
quarter thanks to the launch of the $500
Xbox one X if you picked up an Xbox one
X last night here in Australia or are
planning on grabbing one tonight in the
US make sure to add us I'm cool dude
Express and I'm temperature s and for
everything Xbox one X related including
our review every game that's getting X
enhancements and everything else you
might want to know and be sure to check
out gamespot.com well here we go a bit
of a PSA for you Ubisoft are giving away
a free copy of watchdogs on PC yes it is
between November 8th and November 14th
although you will have to sign up for a
you play account you know whether they
get it yeah but oh yeah as always a
catch hey Dan looks like you need a
shave no I'm giving you a window tell me
in comments panel but if that's
something that I I deal with on a daily
basis there's something else that a lot
of men deal with what depression that's
why I'm not sure because it's no-shave
November / Movember in support of men's
mental health so if your if you do and
you're a little bit sad you know nothing
wrong with that go and talk to someone
about it make yourself feel a little bit
better cool all right so that will deal
with the beard for the rest of the month
yeah yeah